c'était le 17 novembre 2018 la france
vivait le premier rassemblement initié
par les gilet jaune la police recensait
alors 280 mille français dans les rues
des manifestants qui dénonçaient la
hausse du prix du carburant et plus
généralement la charte est de la vie le
mouvement a perduré tous les samedis
dans le pays avant de s'essouffler lors
des restrictions qu'ovide aujourd'hui
mobilisation nationale pour marquer
l'anniversaire des trois ans cortese
dans toute la france dont la capitale
est dans le cortège parisien on trouve
tout de suite notre reporter nadège
abderrazak
bonjour un adage alors c'était plutôt
tendu tout à l'heure quand est il
actuellement est ce que le calme est
revenu
à écouter à venir à on peut parler de
calme mais un calme précaire puisque la
tension est toujours aussi palpable en
revanche ce qu'on peut noter un essai
que à les forces de l'ordre semblent
avoir repris le dessus sur cette
manifestation alors en début de ce2 de
manifestations en début d'après-midi
leçon paru fébriles ils sont parus
rapidement débordé peut-être à cause de
l'importante affluence de cette
manifestation aujourd'hui en effet ils
sont plusieurs milliers de manifestants
de gilet jaune à avoir fait le
déplacement pour ce troisième
anniversaire dr gilles hession
déplacement depuis les quatre coins de
la france alors des affrontements ont eu
lieu tout au long de l'après-midi entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre du
mobilier urbain a été dégradé plusieurs
feux de poubelles sont à déplorer les
pompiers et bien sont intervenus pour
éteindre ces feux alors en ce qui
concerne les revendications elles sont
les mêmes que depuis le début du
mouvement en novembre 2018 je proposais
ce sujet est d'écouter est certain en
manifestant que l'on a interrogé en tout
début de manifestation tout à l'heure en
fait j'ai encore là aujourd'hui parce
que le pouvoir d'achat des français
comme tout le monde le sait aujourd'hui
c'est une catastrophe en fait là c'est
même pire encore aujourd'hui qu'au début
des mouvements du gilet jaune donc là
aussi je suis là parce que je suis
complètement contre macron sa politique
en fait j'aime pas du tout en fait son
comportement qui là bas qu'il a envers
les français nous prendre pour des
petits gens comme nous appellent donc
voilà là aujourd'hui on est là parce que
moi personnellement je suis absolument
contre le vaccin qui est une infamie qui
fait beaucoup d'effets secondaires etc
et promu complètement de façon folle par
le gouvernement et puis le passage du
ter évidemment et on est très inquiet
parce qu'on a vu à rotterdam la sueur
des tirs sur des manifestants ça devient
très très grave il ya tellement de
choses qui vont pas en commençant par
l'école
la santé moi ça va faire depuis décembre
2018 que je suis soit sur les ronds
points soit à manifester mon
mécontentement mais ce mécontentement
elle en train de se construire là on
essaie de faire quelque chose qui ait du
sens et ce sens c'est l'humain d'abord
moi je travaille avec des enfants qui a
en 6e sont analphabètes parce qu'on a de
moins en moins d'heures de cours de
français
l'un de moins en moins de remplacement
l'institution nous oblige à être dans le
mal être
[Applaudissements]
chantée de m
de cette terre manifestation aujourd'hui
qu'hier
en début d'après midi mais qui avaient
ce conseiller de rôle à venir avec des
jeunes et bien
qu'on ait un
style
des manuels mais en ce moment est bien
là
[Applaudissements]
et bien
très peu de choses an de l'élection
présidentielle qui aura lieu dans cinq
mois encore le moment il se montre
toujours déterminés à faire entendre
leurs revendications
[Applaudissements]
merci à 90 ans est très bien les
chansons derrière lou et